okay thanks so this workshop as we all
know is on complexity and simplicity and
we often interpret these terms in the
context of mechanism design which is you
know definitely very appropriate will
hear a lot about it in the rest of the
week I decided to try and think about
these concepts in the context of
networks and so what I'm going to talk
to you about today's agents performing
simple behavior in a network context
that as a result gives rise to some sort
of global structure of societal
significance so the human condition is a
fundamentally networked one many
important games that we play that govern
human behavior are played in a network
context as defined by our social
networks or our business relationships
or our geographical network or networks
of ideas this beautiful picture I found
on the blog All Things graft and it's a
picture of the Wikipedia network related
to the human condition and for those of
you so every node is a web page and the
links are linked hyperlinks between the
web pages and an automated community
detection algorithm found the following
clusters that are what the essence of
the human condition and the people here
are the main contributors to those
clusters so you can see what's going on
there mostly I included this because
it's a beautiful picture of a network so
in network context we have the
fundamentally local interactions so
people are going to interact locally
with their neighbors in this network and
these local interactions are going to
give rise to a global emergent structure
so here for example is a geographical
network this is a 2d lattice every point
in this lattice is colored red or blue
and the points are you can think about
them as agents they want to be in a
local
bourhood that is in which they are not a
minority so initially we have everything
is colored randomly and as the agents
move you can see these local
interactions that they want to be not a
minority in their local neighborhood is
giving rise to a global sort of
structure in which we have not as much
integration as in the initial picture
but we have some sort of like mixture of
sort of local homogeny but global
integration and so this demo was sea-mew
it's a simulation that was written by
Brendan and Brendan Bobby and I are
working on trying to formalize some
notions of this global structure as a
result of these local behaviors I'll
talk a little more about shelling this
simulation in a 1d setting and later in
this talk so I'm going to discuss the
Conte's thesis through the following
three examples first I'm going to
describe cooperation as an emergent
structure in a networked setting so
social networks it's pretty obvious that
in a community members of a community
tend to cooperate with each other often
despite strong incentives to cheat and
gain on one's partner and this is true
even in tech mediated markets like
online gaming ecommerce sites the
sharing economy where the incentives to
deviate are strong and also that it's
not that easy to punish somebody for
cheating because they can always re
enter the system under a new pseudonym
so there's a large degree of anonymity
in these tech mediated markets so why do
people cooperate what we are going to
argue in this paper is that cooperation
arises as the network and the behaviors
co-evolved giving rise to the formation
of a sort of social capital whereby
social capital here I mean the degree of
friendships of a cooperator so a
cooperator by cooperating can build up
many many relations
chips and this social capital is very
valuable to them and it's costly to
destroy so there's sustains cooperation
this is joint work with Brendan and
Brian Rogers so we remodeled cooperation
using a prisoner's dilemma game as a
standard in the economics literature
this is a by matrix game there's two
agents they can choose to cooperate or
defect mutual cooperation gives the
payoff of one to each agent but by
defecting on a cooperator you can gain
an amount of a at a cost of B to your
partner and mutual defection has a
payout of zero to each agent so iterated
a deletion of dominated strategies you
can easily see that the dominant
strategy here is for both agents to
defect however for appropriate setting
of the parameters a and B will see that
mutual cooperation is the socially
efficient outcome and so this is used to
model cooperation and certainly in a
single shot game there's a strong
incentive to defect and we do see
defection in laboratory experiments with
a single shot game but in society we see
a lot of cooperation and so there's a
bunch of theory that's been developed to
explain cooperation in these settings
and sorry this classic result here is
the folk theorem which says that in a
repeated setting of this game agents
will cooperate because if they're
sufficiently patient because they would
rather sustain the cooperation pay off
in the future than cash out on the
defection pay off today we also have a
lot of literature explaining cooperation
and network settings the things that are
able to support cooperation and network
settings range from a sort of community
enforcement norm through a grim trigger
strategy in which if you ever see any
defection used effect on all your
partners and this will spread like a
disease throughout the network and so
the threat so you will eventually get
defected upon yourself and the thread of
this prevents you from
in the first place we also see
reputation mechanism sustaining
cooperation and this is for example in
ebay or structured exogenous penalties
for new members of the community and
there's a line of economics literature
analyzing that in our paper as I've
mentioned what we're going to show is
that the coevolution of networks and
behaviors will sustain cooperation
through the formation of social capital
and the neat thing in our model which I
haven't seen before is that we're able
to sustain a mixture a heterogeneous
mixture of cooperation and defection so
it's not necessary that the entire
society cooperate we can support in a
stable equilibrium fraction society
cooperating an infraction of society
defecting so let me introduce the model
to you it's going to be a repeated model
played in a network setting every day
the following events happen first we
have a population churn so the agents
are going to die with probability 1
minus Delta and then in order to keep
the population size static we have new
agents that are born to replace the dead
so you can think about this Delta it's
plays the role of a discount factor
after that agents are going to we have
the network formation step so agents are
going to form relationships and we're
going to bound the number of
relationships that an agent can sponsor
by some parameter K so the links here
are directed each relationship is
sponsored by some agent and the number
of relationships you can sponsor is at
most K so agents with less than K
sponsored relationships perhaps because
their partners died or they chose to
sever those links those guys can propose
new relationships and then when you get
a proposal for a relationship as an
agent you can choose to accept that or
reject it so agents that receive
proposals either accept or reject them
maybe we get the following network
notice that because of the bounded out
degree there's also an implied bound on
the total number of relationships that
you can have as an agent and we believe
that our results will also work if you
just want to write that into the model
instead of having this sponsorship type
thing going on so after that the agents
are going to play the prisoner's dilemma
game on all of their links and in this
game each agent is going to choose some
strategy that they're going to play on
all of their relationships so you can
either choose to cooperate or defect and
you do that on all of your relationships
and then after people choose their
strategies the payoffs are realized and
the agents can sever any links that they
choose to so for example maybe this
middle agent who chose to cooperate is
going to sever the links to his partners
that chose to defect on him both the one
that's sponsoring the relationship to
him and the one that he's sponsoring the
relationship to something like that
happened so that this is the the stage
game this is repeated over time in every
round when you have a new relationship
proposed to you the sense there is
complete anonymity in our network you
don't know anything about the identity
of that person or his past behaviors and
what we're going to show is that in this
model the following simple behavior is
in fact an equilibrium that gives rise
to an interesting global structure so
the first thing is consistency which
means at Birth I'm going to assume that
everybody is going to pick whether to
cooperate for their entire lifetime or
defect for their entire lifetime and
they pick this with a probability Q next
is exclusivity so when a cooperator so
defectors are always going to accept in
links that's the best dominant thing for
them to do but when a cooperator season
in link they
should decide whether to accept it or
not and whether they want to accept it
or not might be a function of the
proportion of in links that are coming
from defectors versus co-operators so
we're going to allow co-operators to
probabilistically except in links and
the exclusivity condition says that
co-operators are going to accept in
links with a probability P so our
behavior here is parametrized by two
probabilities q the probability with
which you choose to cooperate and P the
probability with which co-operators
choose to accept in links for those of
you that remember the conference version
of this paper the journal version which
is what I'm talking about now this is
exclusivity condition is the new feature
and it allows us to sustain our results
for a larger range of parameters it was
the same for yes it's a quote global
think you don't mean that in each stage
I know at birth you choose this and then
you do that for the rest of your life so
given that everybody's cooperative you
know given a sort of a pea and a cue the
link management portion of your strategy
is determined clearly if you know that
people are being consistent then you
should be unforgiving meaning you should
break links to people that you see
defecting on you and you should be
trusting meaning you should keep links
to people that have cooperated with you
in the past and this link management
policy is what gives rise to the social
capital basically if you're a cooperator
when you get an in link from another
cooperator that's going to be sustained
throughout the lifetime of those
co-operators and this means that
co-operators can build up their
neighborhood to be larger than that of
defectors in fact they can have as many
as twice as many relationships as the
defectors over their lifetime and so now
I want to argue that this simple
behavior forms an equilibrium in the
system in order to see that I'm going to
you know in the paper we derive formulas
for when people are indifferent between
being consistent and being exclusive and
show some fixed points of these formulas
I'll do this pictorial
in this talk so we have the consistency
if I'm going to be probabilistic about
whether I decide to be a cooperator its
effector I must be indifferent between
these two conditions in equilibrium so
we can write down the consistency
condition which says if everybody else
is playing this behavior with parameters
P and Q when am I indifferent between
cooperating and defecting and similarly
we can write down the exclusivity
condition which says that when our
co-operators if everybody else is
performing with PQ when our co-operators
indifferent between accepting and
rejecting the in links so to understand
why the graph looks like this I've
chosen some particular parameters of my
prisoner's dilemma game and my patients
a B and Delta and let's see if we can
understand the regions in this plot so
first if the cue the proportion of so
this is the probability with which
someone cooperates at birth if people
are unlikely to cooperate at birth the
proportion of co-operators in the
population is pretty small so even if
they're accepting in links with a high
probability it's not going to be the
case that a cooperator will be able to
build up the social capital during his
lifetime and so it's better to defect on
the other hand if there's a lot of
co-operators in the world even if
they're accepting in links very rapidly
it could be the case if a is high enough
that you prefer to defect because even
if you totally built out your social
capital you maxed out your social
capital you would still be better off
with half as many relationships
defecting every time if a is high enough
I am bored when I'm bored I have no
choice you flip yeah you flip a coin
with probability cute i want to argue
that doing this this prescribed strategy
is a best response for you so I need to
see when when I get fixed points of
these conditions yeah
a and B are the parameters of the
prisoner's dilemma game so a is the gain
that you get by defecting on a
cooperator so the defector payoff is 1
plus a so if a is very large it's very
very beneficial to defect be more than a
it's 1 plus a vs minus B so you need 1
plus a minus B to be greater to be a lot
of 2 less than 2
in order you're asking about when is it
social welfare to be mutual cooperation
probably over by the assessee together
like that but you of you want to prove
you you ought to fight on each other
which this this is an equilibrium this
besides our acrylic ribbon yes what is
the strategy space so let's try yet it
we develop formerly the strategy space
in the paper you have a mapping of the
observed history to your actions and the
history that you observe is you can
think about yourself as a computer with
many ports on every port you observe the
history of play on that port but you you
don't know yeah you don't have memory of
others so you don't know like that
there's this guy named crystals that
keeps defecting on me yes sure alright
so then so the in these regions you
would prefer to defect even if when
everybody else is playing according to
that particular PQ in this region so now
let's imagine that maybe there's not
even very much cooperation but the
co-operators are pretty exclusive so
they're they're hesitant to start
relationships with people that means
that defectors the number of effective
relationships that defectors can form
every round is dampened by P the
probability that co-operators accept
relationships however you know if the
Delta is high enough so co-operators are
long lived there still ventually able to
build up a full social capital so
they're being able still able to max out
there Nate their neighborhoods and so
you can imagine that you'll get a area
here where because of this exclusivity
we're able to sustain the cooperation
the choice to cooperate at birth
so that's for the the consistency so we
get some shape like this where newborns
aren't different between cooperating and
defecting when everyone else in the
world is playing according to PQ we also
should look at the exclusivity condition
and understand when a cooperator is
indifferent between accepting and
rejecting end links and this of course
depends on the proportion of in links
that are being thrown from co-operators
vs defectors if there aren't very many
co-operators in the world then the in
links that are being thrown are going to
come more from defectors and so you
prefer to reject all in links on the
other hand if there are many
co-operators and the in links that are
being thrown are going to be largely
from co-operators this is because
co-operators keep dying so new
co-operators common are throwing in
links and so you'll prefer to accept in
links but this is the interesting region
here which is that even if co-operators
are not that frequent if they're
exclusive it takes a long time for them
to search for other co-operators and so
we get a lot of in links being thrown
from co-operators and so the exclusivity
and difference condition is going to
look something like this so the
interesting thing about this is like
well first of all any place where these
two curves cross is going to be an
equilibrium and the cool equilibrium
here is this one it's in fact stable
which means that if the population is
perturbed a little bit somebody trembles
and makes a mistake about being a
newborn that's cooperating or accepting
rejecting in links it will self-correct
and return to this point so this is a
pretty stable prediction in this
particular game and it has a mixture of
cooperation and defection yeah amateurs
avian Delta
yeah so this is all dependent on the
parameters a B and Delta we can get all
the shapes our ways like this but it
could be that this red line is up here
meaning that full cooperation is the
stable equilibrium or it could be that
the red shape is completely included in
here in which case full defection is the
only equilibrium and is that you I could
leave them always maybe top left corner
or bottom bottom left is always in
equilibrium so it's always an
equilibrium for everybody to defect and
never accept any in links okay so this
is the the sort of interesting
cooperation story I had to tell we had a
simple sort of prescribed behavior and
we were able to see this neat mixture of
cooperation and defection in the society
due to this sort of exclusivity and it
required this sort of exclusivity on the
part of co-operators the second example
I'd like to discuss is segregation so in
1969 Thomas Schelling introduced a model
of segregation in which agents are not
inherently racist but they'd like to not
be a minority in their local
neighborhood and if they are a minority
in their local neighborhood they're
going to swap houses with other people
until they find a place where they're
happy and so we show in this paper that
these sort of dynamics are going to
cause segregation on a local but not
global scale and this is therefore the
emergence structure that we're
interested in and really what's going on
in this paper is that in the initial
conditions neighborhoods with a slight
imbalance that are you know slightly
more red than blue are just a very
slight imbalance is enough to cause that
local neighborhood to tip at which point
it becomes immune to immigration and so
since this is happening very frequently
we're going to get a lot of local
neighborhoods that are monochromatic but
they're very mixed at a neighborhood
scale so that neighborhoods themselves
are in an integrated pattern so to see
this happening let me
just find the model a little more
formally i'm going to i showed you a
simulation in the beginning on a 2d
lattice we actually we're currently
working on that model but our results
that i'll ever tell you about today that
we have formal proofs of our in a 1d
lattice so initially every node is red
or blue with probability half you for
each node you can define the
neighborhood of that node which is the w
guys on the left of that node the w guys
on the right and that node itself so
that's 2w plus 1 notes and we say that a
node is happy if at least a towel
fraction of his neighbors are of the
same type as he is so in this particular
picture this red node is happy because
he has two neighbors that are red and
two that are blue so the important
parameters in this model are going to be
the window size W and the size of the
society and each day i ate yet i'm going
to use a half in the results i discuss
now it's interesting to look at how
ranging as tau gets smaller people are
becoming more tolerant and so i'll
discuss in a few slides what happens as
tau as people become more tolerant so
each day what happens is I'm going to
select two individuals at random this is
the simple behavior part and if they're
both unhappy and oppositely colored
they're going to swap neighborhoods and
because tau is point 5 or even less than
any towel between zero and point five
that means after they swap they'll be
happy so in this setup for example this
blue node is unhappy and also this red
node is unhappy and therefore they're
both going to swap neighborhood swap
houses and now they're both happy
because before there was a majority read
in this neighborhood now there's a red
guy there before there was a majority
blue in this neighborhood
now there's a blue guy there but notice
that because of this swap we could
create new unhappy notes for example
this note when this used to be red was
happy and now he's unhappy so what's the
result of this simple behavior what sort
of setups could we end up in you know
what what are the final configurations
what might they look like well you can
imagine two things like two extremes and
CZ to come up with in one extreme we
have sort of global segregation on the
scale of the size of the society in
which we have half the ring being red
and half the ring being blue in the
other extreme we have local segregation
on the size of the neighborhood so we
can have alternating segments of length
w plus 1 now every guy at the edge of
one of these alternating segments has
exactly half that are the same color as
him and half their different color so
he's happy so even the marginal guys are
happy so these are sort of two different
very different predictions qualitatively
different predictions we have global
segregation versus local segregation and
more formally i can define segregation
to be the weighted average run length in
the converged final state so in Prior
work while in shellings beautiful 69
paper he simulated this process using
coins on a on a grid on a checkerboard
and he noted that well or on a ring he
noted that for small size societies the
segregation for N equals seventy and W
equals for the segregation was like
twelve which you know is that like and
over two or is that like W plus one who
knows then in 2001
young did a perturbed analysis of this
dynamic in which agents makes mistakes
when they decide whether to move or not
with some small probability and so you
know I think I'm unhappy even if I'm
happy with some small probability and as
we send that probability 20 we can look
at the limit and the limit showed global
segregation but in our paper we do an
exact analysis and we see only local
segregation so there's you know passing
to the limit is there's something going
on here that's not reflective of the
actual dynamic when you pass to the
limit and then following our work so
this is an answering Eva's question we
were this group Lewis pay at all showed
that as you vary the tolerance of agents
you get varying amounts of segregation
it's always local in the sense that it
doesn't depend on the size of the
society but it could be more or less
size of segregation so as agents get
more tolerant we get larger segregation
at first yeah these two is a
commissioning for you and and this has
also two different analysis no these are
exact analysis no Randall mistakes
there's no random mistakes is happening
because he takes it in eight though
because there are mistakes and mistakes
yeah I mean he takes the limit so he
gets an analysis for if there are
mistakes with epsilon and then if you
take that epsilon 20 you get order n you
could say yeah people actually do make
mistakes in society and so his analysis
is more predictive but it's not the
original dynamic yeah
that's kind of a stable I could this
doesn't say anything about the stability
of a situation I'm not exactly sure how
to interpret that but yeah I don't know
yeah this is the goodness the expected
sighs oh thank you yeah they are the
weighted average so yeah oh yes tabbed
analysis are the mistakes just straight
mistakes are they kind of proportional
mistakes in measurement it's been a
while since I read the paper I believe
they're proportional though so here's a
version to interpret this question you
think if i take the perturbation your
limit it's saying that you limit is not
stable I see if you take the perturbed
revision then yes yes yes yes
okay so and this is the result that we
get actually in the stock paper we just
have a w squared here we've since
improved that to linear but it's sort of
the same qualitative statement that
local these dynamics give you only local
segregation and to see why I this is
yeah go to exponential where your oh
yeah I didn't talk very much about that
so this and actually in the 2d model
where we're actually analyzing half
minus epsilon right now so as you take
the tolerance down so people become more
tolerant as we take tau down people
become more tolerant so as I'm more
tolerant say half minus epsilon
initially almost everybody is happy
right because you're expected
neighborhood composition is half half
and so you're you're likely to be happy
and there's sort of exponentially far
apart pockets where there are unhappy
because their neighborhood composition
is far from its expectation and those
neighborhoods are going to start growing
those neighborhoods tip and they become
on a chromatic but they're very far
apart and there's nothing to stop them
from you know the people at the edge of
those neighborhoods become unhappy as
the neighborhood approaches them and it
encroaches on this initially like
complacent okay people and this wave of
immigration is just going to grow and
grow and grow and only thing that stops
it is one of the other initially like
exponentially far apart places that are
growing in the opposite color in the
opposite direction so what happens is as
I get tau people become a little more
tolerant I get exponential segregation
and then as I people become incredibly
tolerant so if I don't if I need like
say it's easy to think about a quarter
of my neighborhood being like me then
I'm even if I'm on the edge of a
monochromatic neighborhood and the
initial configuration I'm likely to be
happy because of the stuff on the other
side and so
as we get very small towels we get a
constant size segregation because
basically nothing changes so your linear
bounded for which stop one half exactly
one half utilizing monotonic and towel
or is it normal to mystic in the size of
the segregation discontinuity yeah yeah
so one has it going to give less the
gregation then one half minus epsilon
yeah so the proof the intuition for the
proof is following this concept that we
define called a firewall if you think
about it any sequence of W plus one like
tights is going to be stable throughout
the course of the dynamics because even
the guys on the fringe of this are happy
no matter what's happening even if this
was a sea of red outside this segment
even this guy is happy and so these
configurations are stable with respect
to the dynamics this already shows you
that segregation isn't global because
these configurations have a probability
of 2 to the minus W of existing and so
every 2 to the w you know lengths i'm
going to have one of these and when as
soon as i have two of these of say blue
I can't have a red neighborhood longer
than length 2 to the w all right so I
the key and the proof so the segregation
isn't most the distance between these
types of firewalls and the key and the
proof is to show that these are actually
very frequent because they get born as a
result of the dynamics so they become
more frequent as the dynamics evolve and
I'm not going to give you the actual
proof of how that happens but the idea
is that if you have a neighborhood
that's slightly more biased in the
initial configuration
say like this part here then as the
dynamics evolved that bias just grows
and so we have a particular
configuration of biases that we call a
fireball incubator that will give birth
to firewalls and we show that these
firewalled incubators are pretty
frequent and you can see this happening
in this simulation which was coded by G
cometh that as time grows the initially
bias things become more and more extreme
until I get a final state where I have a
mixture of red and blue neighborhoods
and so this is the emergence structure
of these local simple local dynamics ok
for more details about that proof you
can ask me offline I thought in a survey
talk I don't have time to go over every
proof in the analysis w should be large
and then it's going to affect the
probabilities in the statement but n is
large much larger and we need pretty a
massive constants so the final setting
I'd like to discuss here is learning so
and we'll hear more about this from Ben
go load later in the week but what we
look at here is thinking about social
networks as aggregating beliefs and we
argue that social networks are effective
at aggregating and spreading beliefs due
to their sparse and expansive structure
so the sparsity there's two phases here
in the first phase the sparsity is going
to allow independent beliefs to sort of
form in different parts of the network
and then the expansiveness is going to
cause it to flood the entire network
such that at the end of the day the
entire network has a consensus on the
majority on the original majority belief
so I have in mind setups like you know
Oh should my baby sleep on her spac or
her stomach everybody had some belief
about this and I want to understand when
do we reach consensus eventually on the
majority belief so there's a blue in a
red state of the world the agents
beliefs are initially either blue or red
and let's say it's biased towards blue
so blue is the majority belief they're
drawn independently across agents in the
network and the opinions of the agents
are initially empty and updated over
time so in this model the beliefs are
private information the opinions are
public information and agents are going
to react they're knit friends opinions
and update their own opinion accordingly
and I want to understand when do all the
opinions match the majority belief so
the behavior that we're going to analyze
which is a sort of behavioral model it's
not a rational model is the following I
repeatedly I'm going to select an random
agent and this guy is going to update
his opinion to the majority of his
neighbor's I don't actually need
majority here I need some boolean
monotone boolean function and then if
there's ties they'll break the tie with
their own belief okay so here the first
agent is asked and he has no friends
with any opinion so he reports an
opinion that's equal to his own belief
then maybe this agent is asked and has
no friends with opinion so reports his
own belief now this guy is asked he has
two friends with opinions and one
without there's a tie among his friends
with opinion so he reports his own
belief now this guy is asked and the
majority of his neighbor's opinions are
blue even though his own belief is red
hill state blue and then maybe we ask
this guy again and he states blue so you
cannot get asked repeatedly prior work
in this model so I'm just here listing
prior work in this model where the
beliefs and the opinions are binary
there's a lot more work when they're
continue
when they come from a continuum which
been golub we'll discuss later but when
its binary we have results saying that
in a synchronous model when every agent
is updating synchronously then I you
know after the first step there's enough
information in the network for an
observer to understand what the majority
opinion was because after the first step
everybody would report their belief as
their opinion but because of the
synchrony we can cause the agents to
converge on a consensus on the minority
opinion the another line of work is
looking at this other sort of effect of
these kinds of models which is
information suppression that means that
even so here if we have asynchronous
behavior even if the agents are
rationally updating after some time they
could start to rationally ignore their
own belief because there's so many
opinions about among their neighborhood
that don't match their own belief that
they start to ignore their own belief
and you get hurting again on a minority
opinion and our result is that certain
social networks are good information
aggregators so we avoid both this
information loss and the information
suppression problems namely we reach
consensus on the majority belief with
high probability and the conditions that
we need are that the networks are sparse
so the max degree is bounded and the
networks are expansive so the second
eigenvalue is bounded away from one we
might be able to relax both of these
we're not quite sure we're working on
that at the moment so too yeah random
three regular yes they will be Sparta
mean they have a bounded max degree and
they will be expensive because I think
so i've woken this a little while before
they remember that if you have achieved
51-percent don't you like you know draft
with random initialization there will be
a linear fraction which will remain at
the minority open African booth we can
talk about it later so to see how this
happens I will give you a sketch of the
proof the first as I mentioned there's
two phases here so the first phase we're
going to have a bounded degree is going
to guarantee that most opinions are
independent so first we have a bunch of
agents developing independent opinions
okay and then in the second stage these
now these different sort of local
clusters of independent opinions the
majority of them are going to be the
right color and the second phase the
expansion is going to cause this color
to spread throughout the entire network
so let's first discuss how we get
majority so my first thing let's see
what agents can impact some particular
guy's opinion unit time T first the
first thing to note I actually skip this
slide but is that the expected opinion
of an agent is going to be blue at the
end of the time why because the opinion
of an agent after the convergence is a
function of the initial underlying
beliefs of the entire society is a
boolean a monotone boolean function and
so if the inputs to a monotone boolean
function are biased towards blue then
the output is bias towards blue but
that's not enough to get our result we
want this to hold with high probability
so we need to talk about the
independence of various opinions and
argue that for sufficiently long then
the opinions of two people are
sufficiently independent such that we
can apply concentration bounds to argue
that the majority is blue with high
probability so too
that you can track the which agents
impact some particular guys opinion at a
time capital T and so you those people
are going to be the people who have
announced an opinion before the center
and are attached to him or before
somebody who's attached to the center
and their opinion is before so i need to
find paths in this graph that started
sometime t have increasing timestamps
and end up at that center those are the
guys that could impact the center's
opinion at time capital T and so what we
need to argue is that the skies I can
impact this centers opinion a time
capital T are disjoint from the guys
that could impact this other random
notes opinion at time capital T and
that's going to be sufficient to
guarantee that these two are independent
so to bound the probability that these
sub graphs intersect we can run the
passes process backwards from the center
and track the growth of these balls and
this is where the bounded degree comes
in so I don't have time to go into this
but because of bounded degree these
balls are growing kind of like coupon
collector problems and so we can allow
something like poly log steps and still
have these things be independent so that
means that after something like linear
number of time steps I have a situation
in which most people have announced an
opinion and more of the opinions are
blue than red now I'm going to use the
expansiveness to argue that after this
now I'm entering phase two so in phase
two every time I ask somebody to
announce they're more likely to have
more blue neighbors than red neighbors
because expansive graphs look kind of
like random graphs which means that the
number of agents that will announce blue
is more than the number that will
announce red if chosen which means that
I have a biased random walk and once
this random walk reaches n I have this
emergent structure where everybody's
opinion matches
the majority belief now i think i'm one
minute over time so i will just conclude
with this light yes coming back to the
first talking is there any sense in
which your nonequilibrium of them until
your pto Gabriel is selected rather than
say P Q equals 0 which is justice that
one and talking on that just one
connection to a statement away the
doctor does not say that people will
cooperate it will night company holy Sh
other than anything is a very serious
issue and that's exactly sure messing up
yes I see um so I don't know how to
select a particular equilibrium I mean
even I don't see why the one we predict
the one we like is more easy to select
than the 00 equilibrium it sort of
depends on where you start if I have a
social norm like you know I start off my
world where people are just nice because
wine let's just try to be nice then I'm
starting at a 11 p equals 1 q equals 1
they will sort of follow self-correcting
dynamics and reach the peak you that I
predict if I start off in a world where
everybody's mean that's implied by the
stability like I mean okay so I need a
little bit of if people are fully
rational and they understand that this
is happening they might you know then
whatever but if they're just
yeah exactly but I be the stability
implies that if they're just sort of
thinking that PQ is stationary they will
reach the peak you that I like if they
start at all being nice if they start at
all being mean then they'll just stay
there yeah so I guess another question
about initial conditions so with the
segregation model we don't think that in
real world people just you know get
allocated randomly at first right
service of this model really seems to
capture something about segregation but
there's also an interesting question of
how did they get in that situation in
the first place well it was tolerance
higher before is something else going up
yeah I look at it more as sort of well
first of all I we were just formally
analyzing the shelling dynamics we
thought was an interesting exercise but
also it kind of informs some sort of
policy recommendations that could be
implied intuitively even to societies
that are already some way along the path
in this process which might be things
like you really need to get these
firewalls to form frequently enough so
you might want to do this by say
introducing low-income housing or
something that's going to really pin
some people to some locations as opposed
to trying to change the tolerance of the
society
people really dislike the Commission
this neighborhoods that changes your
dynamic where the fire was become bad
rather than good and then that really
changes things yeah there there are
definitely models looking at shelling
segregation with this preference for
heterogeneity and they segregate
strongly also so even if people prefer
heterogeneity the society will segregate
which is saying the society will not be
stable which I can imagine the
segregated areas around your mother they
move it there I'm happy so I I don't
know yeah iron since maybe the answer is
that those dynamic visual outcome but I
can't imagine
I'm not entirely sure I don't know that
literature right way but we have a break
coming up I promise to multiple people
the better assessment practices is the
person who will summarize the discussion
and that person definitely real what
this tape is that discussion and it's
supposed to be covering everything and
then taken care of by having this guy
okay we have a break coming up and we'll
be back in 10 15 for further talks in
one